[Music]
that's a drummer Quest love and his band
The Roots the grammy-winning musician
and DJ has done a lot during his
pioneering career Pioneers work he's won
three Grammys as a member of The Roots
he's been a producer for some of the
biggest names in music like Jay-Z John
Legend and name a few he's also won an
Oscar for the documentary The Summer of
Seoul thank you very much and now he's
the author of a new book for young
readers it's called the rhythm of time
it's about a seventh grader named Raheem
who travels back in time in 1997 and
accidentally interferes with history
Quest love joins us now live and in
color in the studio congratulations to
you because this is not your first book
but it's your first children's book yeah
it's your first one yes and you said the
character Raheem was inspired by your
own childhood growing up in Philly yeah
how so because in the book The raheem's
dad didn't want him to be a rapper
didn't really want him in music was that
sort of your life when I was reading it
you know my own father
you know when you're growing up in this
time period I think for a lot of black
parents and for black people in general
like fight or flight and safety is the
only thing that you're concerned with
like we're really not given a platform
to dream or fantasize so even doing this
book was sort of me not dismissing that
fact but uh you know people think about
I'm joking when I say that my dad didn't
even know about the roots into our
second album how was that how is that
possible uh if you look on the front
cover of our first album there's no
photo of us
um you know he just my father's plan was
for me to go to either Juilliard or
Curtis music institute like you know
like Kate Blanchett wasn't tar like yeah
that's the world he wanted for me
because he you know he's thinking of
safety and respectability and not you
know what he thought rap music was well
the father plays a very key role here
there are a lot of plot twists and it
involves about going back in time which
I also thought was interesting but you
said you wanted characters that normally
aren't seen in children's books friends
yeah you know for a lot of us especially
with
even we tell or any form of of media
um I often didn't see myself in those
characters so you would have to sort of
vicariously
imagine that you're Marty McFly or like
when you're watching Star Wars pretend
you're someone else then Lando
Calrissian or whatever
um so for starters yeah I wanted to
write a book that I wish I got to read
when I was 11. I'm a music nerd not to
mention the the idea of like what we
call alt black kids
all black kids I mean that's you know I
walk
yeah I mean you know I didn't I got
teased for the way that I spoke English
you know my mom was stylish so I would
wear like holes in my jeans and paint on
my clothes and
um I didn't look like the rest of the
kids I my AF my hair always was this big
and so
um I I just wanted to write a book that
has kids see themselves yeah you know
he's dedicated to your nine-year-old
self yeah no no go ahead Tony yeah well
I was gonna say well no I have dumb
questions
yeah there's no dumb question but I I
love that you love Prince uh and of
course we're looking back uh Prince left
us this is the month
um he was such an had a profound impact
on you your life
um tell me about that what was it like
what was your last memory of it you know
what
um one of one of my favorite memories of
him was the day that the roots started
The Tonight Show people weren't used to
seeing us dressed in suits and he just
happened to be in town and the second he
saw me he was like shocked and he
reached in his pocket like Prince has a
wallet
and he pulls out he pulls out a 50
bills I say are you tipping me for
looking good yeah you look sharp and I
was like is this 50 a month yeah and I
framed that fifty dollars inside my
house so so do you remember here's my
dumb question uh you know uh when Chris
Rock was slapped at the Oscars uh there
was a there was a an award that was
being handed out there do you remember
who won I won who won that award yeah
that was mine that was my award yeah
um a documentary summer love summer of
souls people always say something I'm
just going to do a sequel for someone
um yeah that was a surreal night but the
thing is is that when your name is being
read in the nominee you're not even
concentrating
on that it's like No Award I've ever
been up for have I've been clear and
present for like okay where's my name
like literally it's like okay remember
remember and I remember saying to my mom
like wait are they allowed to curse like
that like I I was distracted Yeah by I
wasn't distracted by what was happening
because I wasn't even focusing and we
were so far back in the theater
that but you know what I remember that
night you won yes you won you are still
winning you are still winning
congratulations look for another
best-selling author title for you this I
said another feather in his cap I
appreciate